good afternoon
it comes a point in every conference
where somebody stands up and
takes a contrary view we've just reached
it I don't recognize what I hear about
the open trade I've heard today I do
absolutely understand the problems that
we all face and I'll go into those but I
think that we are much further ahead in
the game than you think we are I'd need
to address three quickly three points
raised by the previous speaker the idea
of a register is already there it's
called v80 I have to keep a registration
of every object i buy from whom I bought
it how I paid and I can assure you that
the tax people are much more onerous
than the antiques Department of the met
secondly we have rigorous due diligence
guidelines which absolutely fit in with
what he wanted there in fact it's a
requirement of membership of our trade
association that every object that is to
be sold for more than 3,000 euros must
be checked with the Interpol database
and indeed other commercial databases
export licenses this sounds so good
doesn't it you can't get anything into
German unless it's got an export license
well this is all very well but if I tell
you that I purchase the most aki
collection which was exported from
licensed under license from egypt in
1947 over a period of 15 years and the
export license there were ten thousand
objects and the export license said 15
cases of antiques it's not a very
helpful document we've talked a lot
today about looted art but it must be
clear to all of us that the greatest
crisis currently facing the world
heritage is the destruction taking place
in Syria and Iraq the major causes of
the destruction are twofold war with
indiscriminate shelling and bombing and
deliberate destruction of monuments by
fanatics in the name of their religion
looting comes a poor third recent lurid
headlines have suggested that the
funding of Isis through the sale of
illicitly excavate
antiquities is the foremost problem and
actively encouraged by the trade this is
completely untrue wild speculation that
tens of millions sometimes even billions
of pounds worth of antiquities are
entering the market from Syria is common
no one with any knowledge of the market
would give a moment's credence to these
ideas although we have no doubt and
acknowledged that amidst the destruction
there is a lot of clandestine excavation
looting taking place there's no evidence
to date of any significant material
surfacing on the market in any event the
licit market is small and the vast
majority of Antiquities have relatively
modest value best estimates and I'm
happy to produce figures to back this up
for you these are facts this is not
speculation best estimates show the
global annual turnover of the open
market for classical and pre classical
antiquities is less than 200 million
euros per annum the proportion of that
consisting of objects from Syria is a
small fraction probably less than ten
percent the illicit market must
necessarily be smaller than that since
pieces which are illicit sooner or later
invariably turn up and as an ex-soldier
I can attest that some sort of sums of
money we're talking about don't buy many
arms so the idea that Isis is being paid
for with Roman tear bottles worth two
hundred dollars each is complete trash
at this point I need to emphasize the
difference between the licit trade and
illegal traffic the listed antiquities
trade has no interest in the illegal
traffic in stolen antiquities the
preservation of our ancient heritage is
as vital to us as it is to anyone else
here the fact that we come from a
different perspective a commercial
perspective does not mean that our
reverence for world cultural heritage is
any less real than yours indeed at its
best the trade is a positive force
devoting large resources to conservation
and research the earliest roots of
archeology started with collectors the
first museum was founded by a collector
it's the jobs of museums to collect and
conserve
the benefit of the public and this is
impossible without a trade the trade has
not always had a good record in the past
in dealing with smuggled material but
things have changed dramatically in the
last 10 to 15 years and continue to do
so our trade associations have actively
collaborated with government in this
country to address these issues I also
acknowledge that much of this change has
been driven by our critics yet they
should also acknowledge that in recent
years we've made huge strides no other
area of the art market now prizes
provenance more than we do and the proof
of this lies in the high price at
auction fetched by those objects with
fine demonstrable ownership history but
we to rely on information and this is
rarely forthcoming from source countries
or indeed from our own authorities
sometimes this is because of a Miss safe
misplaced sense of pride sometimes
because of lassitude sometimes it must
be said because of corruption even close
to home we deliberately denied access to
information earlier on was mentioned the
so-called burkina archive are named
after a man who hasn't even been
convicted and this archive is jealously
guarded by an academic in cambridge and
morsels of information drip fed how on
earth are we supposed to conduct our
necessary due diligence in the face of
this attitude okay that's the past now
let's talk about the future the real
question for all of us is how much can
be salvaged from these wars and by what
means what is needed is not
breast-beating and demonization of the
trade but new and accurate data that
provides better grounds for answering
these questions it is for governments
and international organizations to
source this information and to pass it
on to those on the ground including law
enforcement museums and we ourselves the
trade but this information must be based
on facts and not on speculation
only then can we halt or reduce
smuggling on the borders of these
countries and perhaps attention at this
point should be targeted on the
countries directly bordering the
conflict zones it is our belief that
much of the material that is being
looted in Syria today is not even
leaving the country or if it is it must
be going to countries that are very
close in the near East so can the trade
open all this we obviously can't help on
Border Patrol's there's no doubt that
admits the destruction enlisted material
is being squirreled away as i say this
really worries us as this material will
necessarily surface on the open market
sooner or later and this could be some
years from now the challenge therefore
is to identify it and where possible to
return it when it's safe to do so we all
agree on that it is clear that the help
of the trade is going to be vital in
confronting this problem and it will
return require a long-term collaboration
those critics of the trade who find
themselves unable to work with us should
perhaps ask themselves if this attitude
is really in the greater interest it
should be clear to you all following
recent events who your enemy really is
it isn't us the keys the problem lies in
information the technology now exists to
record objects cheaply and we would
suggest that UNESCO should provide the
support to allow the vulnerable museums
and in particular off-site storage
facilities to photograph all their
holdings once an object is recorded the
chances of recovery improved to an
enormous extent the same applies to
above-ground archaeological sites this
is of course no help in the case of
clandestine excavation but it's a start
the issue can also be tackled from
another direction my trade association
is working on a project which is
intended to record objects which are on
the market in perpetuity this is
intended to build up a database of those
objects which can be legally traded
without question while providing an
opportune
to you for potential claimants to
identify those which are stolen this is
a huge demonstration of good faith and
it will also make life much more
difficult for those who deal illegally
and make no mistake we talked about new
laws being needed but this is illegal to
deal in stolen antiquities from Syria is
already illegal it's something for which
you can be jailed no sensible dealer
wants to get involved in that we're
willing and ready to play our part which
we regard as a vital one and I say to
you that if you want to suppress the
black market you should support the
white and that would include allowing
more freedom of movement for legally
held objects less border controls less
export requirements or have export
requirements but actually give export
licenses for heaven's sake why not if
somebody's owned a piece in Italy for a
hundred years why shouldn't they be able
to sell it on the world market why don't
they have to go through this farrago
every timing and everything is blocked
so support the white trade and you will
attack the black finally I have to say
that the best way of curtailing all this
mayhem would be right earning the region
to peace we all know that and at least
we dunas can't be blamed for the war
that is something that our governments
have to think about and by the way I
might mention that before the Iraq war
the second Iraq war i wrote to Tony
Blair begging him to put a tank in front
of the museum once they took Baghdad I
got no reply of course the British
postal system is very unreliable
the first thing I heard from the
government was a letter from them once
the bag Mekdad museum had been looted
asking me what my trade association was
going to do to stop this stuff coming on
the market and I have to say that my my
answer to that was pretty anglo-saxon
when I think of Nimrod I feel like
weeping I've never been and now I never
will i have saved 15 seconds of my
allotted time for us to just think about
Nimrod r.i.p